with a resolution mandating un
peacekeeping operations in southern
Lebanon set to expire on Thursday night
a last-minute compromise at the security
Council to Stave off a crisis and
possibly maintain a fragile peace but
they were tough negotiations on the
annual renewal of the United Nations
interim force in Lebanon the mission
known as unifil at issue freedom of
movement language added to the
resolution last year has allowed unifil
soldiers to carry out unannounced
patrols along the Lebanese Israeli
border freely and without the
authorization from the Lebanese military
the Lebanese government and Hezbollah
which wields great political power in
the country wanted language permitting
unannounced unifil patrols to be removed
from the resolution and lobbied hard for
it
this is called sovereignty if Lebanon
tied with the utmost effort to introduce
any amendments or changes to the
resolution it was prompted by a keen
understanding of maintaining Lebanese
sovereignty and the sovereignty of the
Lebanese government
the council was at an impasse but struck
a deal on Thursday just hours before the
resolution was set to expire which would
have thrown the entire peacekeeping
Mission into turmoil the new resolution
that was agreed upon states that unifil
should coordinate their patrols with the
Lebanese military but also reaffirms
unifil's Independence and freedom of
movement to conduct patrols unannounced
when and where they deem necessary
colleagues we believe the resolution
adopted today and the broad support for
it reaffirms unifil's strong mandate and
its freedom of movement and so we
strongly endorse it it's now uncertain
how hezbollah's Secretary General Hassan
nasrala will view the compromise deal he
signaled recently they wouldn't accept
any compromise the meeting is adjourned
a deal that tried to satisfy everyone
might look good from the confines of the
council chambers in New York but how it
plays out in reality on the border
between Lebanon and Israel is still an
open question Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera
at the United Nations
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera